so through the magic of the internet I
found out there's a Corgi meetup group
in New York we're talking 60 70 80 90
100 corgis all in one place so I emailed
my co-workers to see who really loves
corgis not telling them that a lucky few
would be coming with me to Corgi Palooza
hi I'm Nikki Clark hey
and we love pork when I was growing up
my mom didn't really like pets so I
wasn't really allowed to have any dogs
or anything I asked for a dog and I got
a little brother dogs are better than
brothers I am an avid Corgi lover my
first dog was a Corgi his name was dude
he was a Chile's fattest little potato
in the world he ate nothing but
cheeseburgers and chicken nuggets for
all of his 16 great years all I know is
they were doing something today with
corgis and that is enough for me
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I can feel your energy are you all twin
well I simply believe puppies and dogs
in the world they're the only dogs to
elicit a crowd and emotion like today
[Music]
this is the best surprise ever
I thought we were exist dog sitting a
couple of corgis we're surrounded by
dozens of forties and it's so many
gorgeous this is my puppy now
[Music]
the best moment had to be when I opened
my eyes and I was surrounded by fifty
corgis I've been getting to hold all the
little ones my pop moment today had to
be watching Clark run around the field
with like seven Cory's chasing after
yeah that was probably my highlight as
well it's a lot for my heart that they
get one time and I honestly just feel
like I could live here every time I see
a corgi on the street I have just such a
strong emotional reaction so you can
imagine seeing 50 corgis all that looks
like my core geek dude just trotting up
to me and playing with me this is my new
best friend Brody I really want to take
them home and really alone
[Music]